alright we got that popping right there
a little bit of audio
a little bit of touch touch let's get
that hitter
hello December
where have you been
celebrate
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all right
happy December guys happy December and
that is Spencer Jacob growl beautiful
beautiful man pretty decent looking guy
you know kind of looked like a I met him
one time he sent me that song on the
internet through the magical web of
electricity you know through that
straight up just you know that
electronic tunnel that that the devil
built and he sent me that song one time
and it just it became that hitter you
know it became that hitter you want to
catch another hitter you can grab that
gray block pizza it's on Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles and they got them stylish
pies man if you ever feel an empty go
fill yourself great block pizza they got
that picante foil that Zangaro huh
that Grecian they got the Grecian uh
used to have a Grecian uh came to our
town once a year trying to sell oil
paintings you know olive oil though you
know in homemade oils and [ __ ] horrible
artwork and the thing is about a bad
artist man sometimes you'll buy that
[ __ ] just to get that bastard away from
you so everybody in our not everybody in
our town but a lot of people had these
shitty paintings because the dude was
such a good salesman you know so
everybody got this horrible [ __ ]
artwork but the guy was just such a good
you know oh you need a you know you need
the artwork you know don't you want this
you know this peanuts worse drawings
drawings and paintings of peanuts [ __ ]
smelled like I mean dude I think he was
using condiments sometimes to to paint
with I don't know who that what the [ __ ]
that dudes deal was but that's life man
that's life in a small town I remember
had they had another boy but live I mean
named Bubba Jenkins and his daddy when
he had uh he was adopted you know he was
picked up out of the ether at a
governmental center you know and that's
a dot
and I mean it's a game show when you're
when you're in foster care your life is
a straight-up game show every time my
parent comes in the room it's just like
daunted that because that's your chance
that's your chance to be that hitter you
know and and he got picked he got
scooped up you know he's probably about
all I remember how old he was when he
got ki you know he got um you know
picked up but he got picked up by some
parents and that's you know and it was
like I think he was like 11 so at that
point you're like a mere six or seventh
round draft pick you know you getting
late you know you were late you were
late round pick and uh and he got picked
up anyway he um
what was this story about - talking
about they've had an artwork Jenkins oh
his daddy used to drive me to school and
his dad was Italian I think he was
Italian I don't know he was kind of
sunburnt and had dark hair and at that
young age in my life I thought that that
that that was Italian you know and he
was sunburnt and had dark hair and he
used to smoke cigarettes inside of his
car and he would his wife wouldn't let
him smoke inside and uh so he would go
smoke outside in the car he would sit in
there and just hotbox his car with them
with them Winston's out there blowing
Winston's and Huff and down you know I
mean this dude was probably 900% muppet
dressed like Johnny Cash and he'd sit
out there and and smoked them cigarettes
them cigarettes and he used to when I
would miss the school bus he would give
me a ride to school and he would and he
would quiz me on my spelling words and
the whole time he'd blow that cigarette
and smoke in my face catch me with that
hit of smoke you know hit just light me
up with that Becky that tobacco Becca
cloud you know he'd be like all right
spell inconvenience and I'd be like I in
C and then he'd hit me with that
that back it back a cloud you know and
then are like man it's hard to smell I
mean it's hard to spell it's hard to do
either one in a in a cloud of smoke and
that is the God's honest truth man
that's the Gospel according to your boy
right here but it's hard to uh spelling
and win an adult man is blowing up that
Becky that Becky smoke into your face
and that was um just another unique man
that that lived in my town growing up
but good to see you guys today it is
Monday December 4th in the year 2017 and
looked at a beautiful moon I don't know
if you guys got that got to get a peek
at it and it might still be out there
even tonight or whenever you're
listening to this but they got that
beautiful moon and that moon man thing
is just like a damn like one of God's
nuts just fell out of his ball bag and
landed in the sky I mean that is that
beautiful I mean it's like somebody just
washed the chocolate off of a damn
almond joy and all that's there is that
big coconut with that nut in it you know
and that's what the moon is a lot of
times it's just that big sweet ball of
sucrose floating up there you know and
that's just a dam I mean that's just one
of Mother Nature's [ __ ] you know
that's just one of them that's just one
of mother nature's marbles and that
thing's beautiful and but if you didn't
get to see it go check that moon because
sometimes we forget to look at the sky I
don't think that's happened to you
recently get to look up at the sky and
remember I get caught down here in
little things on my phone you know
looking at papers you know seeing what
my neighbor's cat is doing you know cuz
a lot of times he'll get out but if I'm
I have a very strange relationship with
my neighbor's cat and some of you guys
know that you know and he'll get out
there sometimes he can tell that's gonna
sound crazy too but if I am in my house
you know pleasuring myself he can tell
it you know and he will wait by the door
sometimes or he will you know do make me
owl noises and meow sounds and
do meowing and he can tell when I am
spending time by myself or trying to be
you know lightly emotional with myself
but yeah that's that that that is a
really wild cat so anyhow it's Monday
and what's going on in our lives today
you know it's December so we're starting
and we're starting to narrow down what's
happening in our existences for this
year this year's gonna be in the books
and you can start to feel it in the air
you know people are a little more
friendly you know I got look I got the I
got the damn I have the Christmas carols
going on full blast in my automobile man
I love the Christmas Carol and Bill be
ringing the ones I don't like Mariah
Carey dude I wish a [ __ ] missile would
hit that you know I wish it would just
hit hit her right in her in there in
that dark cinnamon [ __ ] of hers I dunno
I just Mariah Carey's a straight Muppet
she's what's wrong with this country
Mariah Carey
you heard it here but what else I was in
Canada I got to play cards with Bill
burr I'll start there so I'll tell you
this they have this uh this this podcast
network called all things comedy and
they've been very gracious over time to
allow us me to have my other podcast
called allegedly on there with my friend
Matthew Cole Weiss and on that same
network there's a new show where
comedians sit and play poker together so
you know I get an email come play and it
was it was a great group Bert Kreischer
Bert Kreischer Bill burr Steve
Rannazzisi who died in 9/11 but didn't
die in 9/11 and Jon REEP who's one of
the first comedians that I ever featured
for down in Louisiana and Jon REEP you
know he's the Hemi guy he's like a bang
got a Hemi
he's from Hickory North Carolina and and
it was just great man we got to sit in a
warehouse have pizza people
drinking alcohol and just play some
cards play some poker together joke
around you know we were just joking
about how hard it is to be a man today
but it was interesting to just be around
bill broom obviously a huge fan there's
no one no one more confident on stage
than bill burr I can listen to that man
forever and he's always like you know
what you're gonna get
he doesn't seem too affected by ego you
know he didn't he doesn't seem he was
super nice like and I spent time around
him before I got a little vibe for being
around it but I never really just sat
next to him for two hours and we're all
playing in a poker game but it was uh
but just a nice guy you know some of
these you know comedians that are at
these you know that are superstars like
Hollywood superstars they get there's an
ego that goes along with it and I think
Bill burr is a superstar comedian but I
don't think he has that celebrity side
as much as others do if that makes any
sense because the celebrity side is kind
of that's the ego the side of the talent
that's the comedian side and man he's
just one of a kind but that was great
for me man I'm sitting there I'm [ __ ]
like kind of nervous I can like feel
Bill like sitting right there next to me
you know we're just sitting at this half
table all playing cards and there's like
about 15 people they're shooting this
this show and like yeah you know I'm a
little bit nervous I know Bert Kreischer
really well I know the other three guys
at the table well you know Bert
Kreischer the Machine and I'm I've known
Bert for a long time in John for a long
time so I feel more comfortable
comfortable around them but to be
sitting there you know next to a guy
who's just man I just felt inspired I
felt really really inspired so that was
a great moment for me just to be able to
be you know in those guys as presents in
a with an activity that we all are doing
together so it's you know it's just
poker we're just playing around and I'm
trying to think of some I mean bill made
me laugh a few times everybody made me
laugh you know I tried to be a little
more quiet and just listen instead of
you know trying to you know put my two
cents into it a lot but it was great man
we
great time that was a real joy and then
I was up in Canada in Calgary let me
tell you this if you ever been a have if
you haven't been a Calgary I'm thinking
like Calgary what is it you know I
didn't even I don't even know Canada was
a real place for a long time I thought
it was just a you know a place where
America practice safety you know and
practice safety equipment who do you
think about Canada you think we'll what
is it you know what is Canada its
America's hat you know it says it's this
cold hat that America wears if you look
at a map and it's like this big cold hat
and and I'll tell you this there's
people up there there's people up there
and they're as friendly I don't feel any
stress when I'm in candy you get there
you don't feel like nobody's
judgmentally looking around there's so
much less judgement like people keep to
themselves but not in a way where
they're doing it to keep away from you
like in America there's this weird and
maybe I feel it more in Los Angeles and
I and that's definitely so like you go
into some smaller towns and there's some
real communities here in this fine
country and you you don't feel it as
much but but in Los Angeles you feel
everybody you know looking over like Oh
who's this my life hey you know who's it
who's this oh look at that big Daniel
you know what is you know full body cast
you know or who's this [ __ ] over here
you know wearing electricity around her
neck with him Louis Vuitton's or
whatever you know who's this oh this
kid's got you know this you know this
kids a gender-neutral sea bass and he
thinks he's a [ __ ] cuz he's got a fin
out of it coming out of his back and you
know for different types of genitalia
between his legs oh you know people
think that they're fancy out here but
you don't feel that in Canada in Canada
everybody's just Canadian you know some
people may have a little more than
others here and there but you know in
the end and everybody it seems like
everybody kind of has each other's back
and now look I've spent I've been in
maybe five cities in Canada
but Canada you could lay down in the
street middle of the street in a city in
a city in a downtown fall asleep and
when you woke up in the morning someone
would have put a blanket on you and cars
that were driving on the street would
have probably shut would have probably
shut their engines off when they got
close to you gotten out of the car and
pushed their car past you as to not wake
you up like that's the kind of people
are just way considerate of others and
it's not like they're trying to be it's
just it's in their nature it kind of
reminds me if I had to guess what
America was like maybe you know 50 years
ago and maybe not for everybody you know
I mean it but you know it'd probably be
I mean Canada's very white so probably
would have you know what America was
like for most people I mean I know there
was a lot of racial tension and struggle
but for regular white people I bet it
was similar it's probably something that
can it is Canada's the diverse two men
they have I mean it's it's pretty white
but everybody's I mean they have a lot
of Hindi and a lot of Pakistani I mean
it's I don't know I had a blast man up
in Calgary I didn't know this about
Calgary either it's like the second
richest city in the world because of oil
they got that drip drip they got that
drip drop at a drop you know damn boy
that oil that oil and what else happened
to me man that was it we flew up there
we had four guys pancreatic cancer is
like a charity function you know we went
and we did it what else we saw had some
fans come on had this gentleman named
Chris came out I think he drove six
hours or something he'd made this
beautiful art for me
that he drew about the HAMP and ain't
easy you know about the tour from this
pet from this year he drew that up for
me it was phenomenal man I just want to
thank him for driving in and and just
bringing that to me really touched me
because they're just nice of somebody to
do that you know to go out of their way
to do something special for somebody
else what else I got back
tonight I wouldn't spoke at an AAA
meeting you know you go to these
meetings sometimes and you know you sit
in there and you talk it like some of
these centers and these centers they
have you know it's guys that are in like
these treatment facilities and you go in
there and you know they got eight or
nine guys in the room and some of them
you can tell like you know they're down
on their luck you know you can feel it
and it's tough because you know I go in
there and I'm just clean on clean I just
got out of a shower at my apartment you
know and you know I drove over there and
like you know my clean car you know and
it's comfortable and I walk in there and
I've clean clothes and you know I have
somewhere to be when I leave I have
something to do the next day and I walk
in and I sit in some of these rooms with
these men and this was an only a men's
only meeting so that's why it was just
me and I sit in there and I'm just
started listening to these guys you know
just saying hello and you could feel
some of them like when they shake your
hand like their hands shake and kind of
and it just it just brings me back down
to like the reality of life of my life
you know of the world that I'm in you
know because I can easily get caught up
running around thinking what do I need
to do next what does my money look like
for the year you know how am I gonna
best turn this next deal thing that's
going on what's my next move to propel
myself you know to think about me and
then I go to these meetings and that's
one of the main reasons I go to these
meetings you know and I don't talk about
this kind of stuff that much on here
because you know part of the AAA stuff
is you're not supposed to talk about it
but you know what I don't whatever you
know this is part of my life sometimes
and and more often than not as part of
my life but I go sit in there and these
these guys and you just and you go
around the room and you share it's
called a panel and there's like three or
four guys and we sit and we share our
story you know we share like what our
story is
you know it's just kind of wild because
you know I went from this crazy weekend
where I was out in you know I'm up in a
different country and I'm doing a show
and there's five six hundred people and
it's you know a sold-out venue and we're
I mean you know we got to be you know we
got to be the the hit you know we got to
be that hitter you know we got to be
that Mackay smoke we were that back a
smoke that was getting all in people's
faces and veins and eyes and then you
know I get off that plane and I get back
in a you know just into a reality that
sets me down and sets my spirit at a
level where I'm just not thinking about
myself and you just share and you share
your story you know when I talk to these
men about you know that I'm not there to
preach to them I'm just there to share
what's going on in my life and just how
I grew up feeling inferior and just
never feeling okay and just always
feeling like I was looking always
feeling like I had everything always
feeling like like I had like things had
to be changed but no matter how many
little ways I changed them
I was never reaching a desired effect
I was never feeling comfortability and
things would be great things would be
great or bad or you know I was never
able to find a comfort you know and
that's just what I started sharing with
these guys and then I come into these
rooms now you know and I go to these
meetings and suddenly I'm in a group of
people and we're all have something in
common and that calm and that
commonality is it's a problem it's a
problem we all have some type of a
problem an addiction or a discomfort or
a uneasiness or a loneliness that's why
we all come to these meetings and and
when I sit in there there's just
something special when it makes me feel
when I'm part of a group when I don't
feel alone even if it's something [ __ ]
up that brought us all together it's
like I don't even care dude I don't care
if we have no all of us have no arms or
less
and no head and we all crawl to this
this body pile up meet up just like a
bunch of boulders and we all just you
know just roll around on each other like
rocks I would probably feel joy in that
just because of the fact that I'm in a
group I think as most of my life I felt
so for some reason on the inside of us
felt so separate you know I just felt
like I just never felt like a part of
something you know and I just never felt
okay and I sit in these groups and you
know when I'm talking to these guys and
and that just makes me feel okay for
some reason and I think a lot of it's
just the connection the connectivity
because we can get separate we can get
separate pretty quick out here so anyhow
man that was my weekend I didn't mean to
get all wild or weird on you there just
trying to share some of what it's like
when you know being in this AAA program
I've been in here for about 16 months
now I don't know if I'll always be in
this program you know I don't know if
I'll always be a part of it but for now
I am and and I'm grateful because I get
to have moments where I go into rooms
and I don't feel alone and the people
that I'm there to share my story with
they don't feel alone and it's crazy
that by sharing our problems you know
are coming together because we have an
issue that is how we don't feel alone
anymore
that's how we solve our problem you know
because forever you're out here trying
to solve your problem all these
different ways when all you really need
it was to fill up that void that makes
you feel like you have a problem in the
first place
so I don't even know if that makes any
sense but something just propelled it
right out of my body I'll tell you what
does make a little bit of sense to me is
that television shows have gotten
horrible they're not entertaining
anymore you know it's so bad a lot of
times your own dog will leave the room
if you have a dog or if you have mice in
the walls you can sometimes hear them
scurry off when you put on a certain
program it's because TV and film aren't
about entertainment anymore they're
about advertisement that's what you have
to understand what your why
is an advertisement cloaked in light
entertainment entertainment is the
secondary goal of the programming you're
watching
well that's changing now because we're
putting things back in the hands of the
people and when I say we it's an
organization called live tree live tree
dot-com you can go there it's changing
the entertainment industry by creating a
new platform called adept the public
will be able to fund what they want to
watch own what they help produce decide
who's in it what goes on through the
process of content creation funding and
distribution it's basically like
suddenly entertainment is going to
become almost like I don't want to say
fantasy football because this this is a
reality but you're going to be able to
invest and then have a say-so and who is
in something and if the project is as
well have a return on your investment
how crazy is that
that is what is going on at live tree
you can go to live tree dot-com and
check it out see what is happening the
revolution is now I'm definitely going
to be over there checking it out myself
all right let's get into the news we'll
go with big news first and then we'll
get into some smaller stuff North Korea
firing missiles a while shoot them off
bro
shoot them off dude that's nothing
I used to know a guy who could spit high
high up in the air and catch it in his
mouth dude every time and that's all you
remind me of North Korea if you want to
shoot something shoot it up pop-pop cuz
y'all ain't doing nothing you're over
there Wizard of Oz and you know beatin
people for chewing gum god forbid
somebody learns to blow a bubble and
you're out there beating them with
sticks or whatever you guys are doing
making people juggle juggle wigs and
stuff and teaching babies how to juggle
and dance and [ __ ] like that I've seen
it on the Internet with those electronic
dancing babies and all of that and I've
seen what you guys are doing over there
you got infants over there riding you
know riding on Gators and doing all
kinds of [ __ ] and wearing neck braces
and stuff
and I don't know what you guys are up to
but shoot your little missiles guy
you're never gonna do anything here's
why because you love your existence over
there yet Yonsei whatever the guys name
is yum tom yeah uh [ __ ] down dowse I was
gonna say douse sang that's not it
something whoever [ __ ] I almost said uh
I almost said um Oh
oby almost said obi-wan Kenobi dude I
don't remember whoever you are bro
you're not doing [ __ ] dude shoot your
missiles dude what else a Navy pilot
drew giant dicks in the sky with a
fighter jet how about this awesome
sounds awesome dude easy though to draw
a dick I think I'd love to see the guy
get a little bit more intimate draw some
vagine out there in the clouds you know
would it be cool to see a big cloud
going by with a nice hoo-ha on it with
that a little bit of a spoiled cookie
out there because I've seen some spoiled
cookies out there especially down in
your Tampa and when you get down here
that Gulf of Mexico they got some
spoiled cookies down there a lot of them
ladies ain't taking care of their
bakeries you feel me
I'm having coffee what else
a grandmother accidentally invites a
stranger to Thanksgiving
I love how that's news now back in the
old days that was just called being nice
grandmother accidentally invites a
stranger to Thanksgiving ah lucky lucky
guy here's another one
undercover Detroit cops trying to rest
each other and then fight [ __ ] yes ah
that might be the best headline I've
ever even read Detroit cops trying to
arrest undercover cops trying to wrest
each other and then what is when it's
not working out for some reason they
fight each other
that's so Detroit I love that look
you know what I always wonder why they
only have undercover cops why is that
the only job where it's you where you're
undercover you know like I would love it
like
undercover stripper you know you're at
the bakery you're buying a couple of
donuts maybe the lady's like oh do you
want these you want these crawlers or
you want these tits and suddenly she's
an undercover stripper you didn't have
any idea you know how great would that
be huh oh you want that bear claw or you
want that fox foot and she just spreads
them gams open you know you want that
bear claw or you want that you want that
uh that eagles under bite you know she
just shows you that cooter good times Oh
Navy pilots drawing dicks in the sky
undercover cops fighting each other it's
like the 80s all over again I love it I
love it people say the world's falling
apart
are you doing okay here's how to know if
your world is falling apart look at your
world talk to your family see what's
going on take care of your home take
care of the people around you
you're good the world isn't falling
apart we're gonna be fine we're gonna be
Fi any I'm just amazed people have so
much time online all day to fight about
all this [ __ ] if you have time to
fight about it then you're probably
doing okay you're probably doing okay
you know what else let's see in my
hometown a Mexican restaurant opened up
in downtown Covington Lousiana and
that's beautiful to see and I want to
say a belated congratulations to the
Covington high school lions from my
hometown they made it to the
quarterfinals and they lost last week
but I know that was huge for them down
there and everybody just bringing the
community together and having some local
excitement and I watch that game on the
YouTube and it was beautiful to watch
and just see you know and hear people
down there you could hear I mean it's a
good community you got all types down
there you got people that can't read and
you got people that can read but it's a
it's a good time and it's a-you know and
I'm just happy for that environment down
there to see your hometown do something
big but they got a new Mexican
restaurant downtown I remember the first
Mexican kid we ever got in my town
and I've told that story before about
Mexican Nicolas when he came to town
beautiful boy
and he had that kind of canary nutmeg
tint on his skin you know and he had
that mustache
you know that word curtain you know a
lot of Latino boys they just they strain
their whole childhood just to sprout
that word curtain you know and he came
into class he came into sex ed we just
started learning about sex ed at school
you know and I thought it was gonna be
this dude named Edie was gonna run in
the room spray out because I'd seen this
fellow working freelance by the by the
train tracks so I'm thinking hell yeah
finally ed is getting his money you know
finally ed is coming up and is getting
work but it's a synonym sexual education
it's a synonym but but he came into
class I remember our principal open the
open the door to our classroom and
science science boy you could hold an
animal at your desk you'd be sitting at
your desk mr. Blackwell was our teacher
sitting at your desk holding a baby
squirrel holding a hamster GP oyster
lizard one kid in our class and he'd
been in a fire he couldn't hold anything
that would scratch his skin so he get to
oyster every time you know he's sitting
in class a little Sherman get that
oyster cuz he came he got them fire
hands you know he got them paper mache
hands you know he can't put anything
real heavy a real spicy on them because
he's already been in a fire and you
don't spice up somebody that's been in a
fire you don't surprise them with any
you know turmeric or any salsa or
anything like that blessed should eat
right through their skin very very
little skin on a fire person so a little
sermon he get that always stir every
time they set that soft oyster in his
hand you know because it wasn't gonna
move or try to scratch him but
everybody's sitting in class you got an
animal you know got a little pet because
we're learning about science you know
usually so you got a piece of science in
your lot in your hand living piece one
of the Lord's little you know one of the
Lord's little dirt puppets you know you
have one of them one of the Lords
one of the Lord's little Voltron's
animal a piece of science on legs a damn
animal something that can [ __ ] do when
you're not around think about that
you ever think about that you ever close
your eyes and think to yourself how many
animals are [ __ ] right now if you
ever got an ego and you want to take
yourself out of ego put yourself in a
reality you do that you close your eyes
think that in the distance right now
there are animals just [ __ ] each
other they're all types animals cats
moose dev not devil worshippers yeah
devil worshipers dude they're not
animals but they're not doing well as
people and what and other to all types
of animals forest is just for the forest
is a [ __ ] fast dude it's an orgy you
think we always think that animals are
just kind of milling around eating these
animals are [ __ ] each other that's
what they're up to
dude you can there's a lot of videos
online I've been online watching a lot
of funerals a lot of funerals online
recently I've been watching funerals
online and and it's kind of crazy I
guess you know I guess it makes me feel
like a part of something you know and I
like to have feelings so I like a
funeral will give you a feeling you know
if you're sitting there watching the
service and people sharing their
feelings and stuff and you can comment
you know they all seem nice you know
some people have rude comments you know
you know there was some rude rude
comments you know
let's see some titties up in this
[ __ ] some dude in all caps like
damn bro you know Dale worked for the
post office I don't think you know I
don't think that's kind of you know
that's the kind of severance package he
was talking about but anyway Nicholas
came in our classroom Mexican Nicolas
he'd been in class you know that our
principal opens the door she said
students he tells a new student and
it was him his first Mexican sat in
class raised his hand but in class four
minutes dude in sex ed he raised his
hand and he said hit mr. black will
would has popped that cherry mean homes
would has pop that cherry mean homes and
he became a legend he became a legend
and that was the first Mexican ever but
now it's great to see that small towns
are evolving you know people want to
look at small towns say these people
aren't diverse we had one shot at
diversity and we made that kid a legend
there's so sick of people saying over
what you know you don't have diversity
you don't have this you know you're that
you're not diverse because you don't
have something yeah you don't know
something until you have it you can't
force something on somebody diversity is
a blessing if you get to live in a
diverse place then you that's a blessing
and if you aren't experiencing it if you
have neighbors that are different and
you're not getting some sort of an
experience with them then you're missing
out you are missing out and that's the
truth that is the truth man a little bit
more news here man accidentally burns
down three buildings and damages 20
others trying to make a sword in his
backyard
well [ __ ] yay did I mean that's obvious
right there
a man questionable there obviously burns
burns down three buildings and damages
20 other buildings trying to make a
sword in his backyard on December 1st a
man was in his backyard first of all
some of these backyards what's going on
back there how much space how much room
you need back there what are you doing
what are you doing back there in your
yard with your [ __ ] equipment and
saws what are you doing you building
swords we'll get it together guy on
December 1st a man was in his backyard a
man with a piece of [ __ ]
it was probably a white man
- you know they [ __ ] everything up sorry
for my language guys imma you know what
I'm not in a bad mood today but I'm just
fired up I'm feisty you know a man was
in his backyard playing Game of Thrones
dude by trying to make his own sword he
got the furnace up and running to melt
the steel bro
use wood bro the only problem was that
there was 30 mile-per-hour winds going
that day and the embers hit nearby
buildings burning down three and
damaging 20 others still waiting on the
update of how the sword turned out well
that's what you get from making swords
right there you lose all your friends
literally you lose all your friends you
cost their friends their place to live
Amazon contractor decides to deliver his
own package by taking a dump in
someone's driveway well that's what
happens when Amazon is trying to you
know same-day delivery I don't have time
to [ __ ] a guy doesn't have time to [ __ ]
because he's got to get a new pair of
sandals to your stepmother what the hell
is going on do you need it that fast
same-day delivery God probably gets
fired or docked pay if he you know if he
is probably an access code on the
[ __ ] if they fight they've you know
if he presses his code in there to go to
use the actual you know room de
digestion then he's gonna get fined so
now the man got a [ __ ] local you know
when he's out and about this week an
Amazon contractor got caught taking a
[ __ ] in someone's driveway
well that's for driving dude it says it
in the word after he placed their
package on the front porch he was caught
on film he can watch that online so if
you want to watch a little bit of local
[ __ ] and going on you can check that out
online but it's just you know they don't
have these guys I'm sure they probably
get fined if they call if they sneeze
they get docked pay they're not getting
the package could they're quick enough
guy breaks a sweat that's probably you
know cause some
dollars man can't even [ __ ] anymore you
know men wearing diapers running around
men and strong women and some lesbians
running around wearing diapers you know
just so you're freaking uncle Marty can
get a you know a a a rare pack of Oreo
cookies it just came out the hell is
going on other news magnitude 4.4
earthquake strikes off the coast of
Dover Delaware well finally Delaware's
in the news I forgot about Delaware
didn't you you did too I know you forgot
about Delaware Delaware what is it it's
Britain basically it's our Britain and
if we had any balls we'd fight him again
you know because they're screwing around
Britain did a lot of [ __ ] that they
don't take any responsibility for we got
James Corden on the air out here you
know as a host of late-night television
when his grandparents enslaved half the
universe what's going on people what
else ranch dressing is finally available
in kegs good and I'm sure that'll help
with I'm sure that'll help run up the
bill of of insurance cost that's got to
be healthy for somebody give you a
freakin a little nephew a thermos of
ranch dressing kids in fourth grade
sitting there sucking down a couple of
you know pints at Thousand Island on his
during recess unbelievable just in time
for the holiday season Hidden Valley
unveiled their brand-new ranch dressing
keg they say it comes with a one-year
supply of ranch in each keg Hidden
Valley that's what they call your
healthy aortas hidden valleys you can't
even see them anymore because you had so
much damn ranch but you know what I say
that's a good way to go to heaven if
you're gonna die I've always been
ashamed that the only ways that we have
to get to heaven are or after if you go
if you you know or to deal with the body
our embalming or
burning I think is the second one you're
gonna burn me guy
oh that's brave you know you seem like a
smart guy you're burning up people that
are dead what an [ __ ]
why don't you go make a sword and burn
down your neighborhood you freaking
sword maker because here's a thing uh
how about this
fill me with [ __ ] ranch baby huh
embalm this little Bobcat with that ra n
CH boo-boo
you're telling me em both you're telling
me that formaldehyde and that and that
and that being ah what's it called when
you're burnt to a crisp you know
whatever it is decapitated or something
are the only things that can happen you
after you die no way more options I
wanna fill daddy's body with ranch I
want to be in bone with ranch take my
eyeballs out leave my mouth open put me
in the funeral casket all my orifices
open a bunch of little things chips
broccoli get them pop pop getting me my
faces you know hit them orifices hit
that mouth I I get that triple dip make
me a little bit of a snack hole that way
people are actually enjoying their time
at my funeral am i showing you know what
about bacon wrap how about you put a
huge slab of that freaking a thick thin
ham around daddy's neck
damn boy have all the dogs barking
outside of that funeral house but you'll
have birds at the window is ready to get
in there and just take a little bit of a
nip nip off that is a freaking head vase
off that neck off that ham
but there's upwe other things you could
do black and dipped baby backed what if
you went to the what if you went to
somebody's funeral and their ribs had
all been cooked and ready to eat
and if you wouldn't have a human rib
you're you're a lying you're a liar and
I tell that I'm you know I'm not saying
it to make fun of anybody of it but if
you wouldn't need a human rib
that had been perfected cooked maybe
over there at Arthur's barbecue or
whatever and Kansas City were in Wichita
wherever that place is you would hit you
wouldn't get that hit huh
you can light it you can lie to yourself
just don't lie to me cuz I'm not
listening to it anymore that's the news
right there really that's the news let's
keep it cruising here we had a couple of
calls on my head um I want to thank you
guys for being here with me I'm in a
little bit of a weird mood man I'm just
feisty you know I haven't smoked in a
whole week I haven't smoked in a whole
week man and I would blow man if you
showed me a newborn baby made out of
nicotine right now I would probably blow
it that's where I'm at but that only
lasts for like about 10 10 seconds then
I get past that you know you know if you
told me right now that a young Viet was
hiding a couple cigarettes in his you
know had a little bit of that back east
smoke in his bloodstream I'd sharpen my
incisors and vamp down on that boy catch
that hitter right out of that right out
of that boys young uh right out of that
uh that dang Tran or whatever you know
that Zang T that River right out of that
Delta that Mekong Delta
just just lats home of that boy's neck
and just get that hitter just [ __ ]
rocking hemoglobin right under that
young viet stream so i could get that
hit of that backe but I'm a weak man I
don't even know how I just I got to the
point where I just was tired of smoking
but then here's what always happens to
me I tell once I tell people I'm I'm
quitting I'm done that's when I start
again it's like if I keep it to myself
then it builds up and it actually works
you know and I'll do it I'll stick to it
but once I start to you know like I'll
go do something from one day I'll go do
some you know curls at the gym or I'll
brush my hair for one day and then I'll
tell people oh you know I'm brushing my
hair now you know I'm doing curls at the
gym now once I tell people
it's oh it doesn't I don't continue it I
don't know what that is I don't know why
that is I don't know a lot man maybe
that's where I'm at all I know is that
it's December you know I do know that I
know that it's December and I know that
uh that I got a call for you guys right
here let's get to it here we go just a
couple just a couple cater with sub
tater Vanna Georgia Savannah Georgia
that's artistic country that's art ISM
and that's where it's paints and clay oh
we want to call and say what's up I'm a
machinist we made parts going airplanes
that's one lesson oh that's what we're
doing out half put you on the radio
playing over the whole plant we listen
to you
y'all about eight of us almost skeleton
crew but I just wanted to let you know
this what's going on with him Savannah
Georgia you got fans I appreciate that
man you guys make parts for airplanes
well guess what I'm gonna say this first
I must say thank you very much you know
I asked last week who listens to this
show and that's why I wanted to play
this so we have a group of machinists
over there in Savannah and they and they
listen to it at their plant they got a
skeleton crew and and thank you for that
man I do appreciate it
I would like to say this your parts are
always running about 30 minutes late
when I'm trying to fly so we just got a
word from the cockpit that we need to
get a new part and we're gonna be
delayed for 30 minutes so if you guys
could step it up after your lunch break
cuz I know you over there is Savannah
you guys out in there having pineapple
upside-down cake and wedding cake for
dessert y'all having catfish and um you
know baked Calif Lauer doing all of that
sweet potato jam Alaia casserole I'm on
fire y'all having that cyka cyka now
y'all having beer with lunch
having wedding cake for dessert who the
[ __ ] is having wedding cake for dessert
on a Tuesday that's the problem sometime
with some of these southern places man
people have into seven-course lunch
[ __ ] it's Wednesday you having a
seven-course lunch this isn't a this
isn't a Bangladeshi wedding okay lunch
is one course get it and get back to
work the second course for lunch is
getting back to work but I want you to
go to College of Charleston man and I
love that area got some beautiful
beaches over there not far from you guys
and I do appreciate you guys calling
let's listen a little bit more here say
what's up and comments for you boy this
uh wanting to bring another guy to the
bedroom with his old lady oh yeah that
was a call that came in last week that
was what the follow-up was about that a
gentleman named Adam who was talking
about doing that cook holding where you
have other people come in and play your
video game system you know cuz someone
you got that ps4 you know that's why you
only get one controller with it because
they don't really want you having
friends on it you know that's why your
wife only has one vagina hole because
that's for you that's for you but this
fellow want to Adam wanted to have
people come over and you know he want to
do Ninja Turtles where he having three
or four guys jump down in that sewer
hole but let's hear a little more dang
gang gang when these people do that it's
just going to cause problems and bring
unwanted issues into the marriage yes
they might seem like they cool about it
at first but uh don't get another fight
let on you know that's good in your face
yeah you heard it man and that's a
hard-working man that man me up there
making airline parts well look I'll say
this also I hope you only smoking weed
out there bro because I fly a lot and if
y'all out there you know catching that
cannabis to the brain shut it down
because I don't want to uh you know a
wing part that you know next thing you
know one of these wing is made out of
feathers and I'm like what the [ __ ] are
they making over there in Savannah but I
love you guys thank you for the support
let's hear a little bit more we had one
more caller that called in about that
the Adams response from last week let's
hear a little more on that thanks for
calling Brent on word about the guy who
was in the situation or situation where
he wanted to watch another man bang his
wife a little bit of science where you
they ran an experiment with the
likelihood of impregnation with a sperm
count how high a person sperm count was
and when they collected the samples they
would send the man home with a bit of
pornography - you know masturbate you
okay interesting so this is an
experiment where a men were where they
did sperm collection and they sent them
in home with pornography different types
of pornography when they were when they
were running this experiment homeward
turns out the men who were given
pornography that pictures gangbang like
multiple dudes with one woman oh yeah
dude you took them out that buffet-style
you talking about that family style like
when you're at a that bloomin onion you
know that thing when you people eating
from all sides of it but yes onward when
people when men got the gangbang
pornography what happened productivity
was much higher in those samples then if
the porno watched only had one man and
one woman
so Wow a little bit of science there
more you need to know your woman could
be taken by another man I mean I
supposedly I'm not saying it's true or
not I'm just saying science says you got
to compete a little bit for that nut
that you're nuts it's gonna compete a
little bit harder that's nuts yeah
that's called a nut off when two people
are trying to you know out nut each
other so nut off you know and they used
to have I remember being in elementary
school in this man mr. Larry I was in
elementary was June middle school and
they back when I went to middle school
if you were in there for long
and I'm spoken about this gentleman
before but if you were in middle school
for long enough then they eventually you
just they couldn't have you take the
classes anymore because you couldn't get
it they would just make you a custodian
and we had a black gentleman in our
school been and probably been in fifth
or sixth grade maybe seven times
mr. Larry finally he got a job custodian
but he was still friends with a lot of
the kids because we all knew each other
you know we'd been in class with him for
a couple years so but mr. Larry would
come in and urinate in the bathroom and
piss over our shoulders you know cuz he
had that hit on him you know he had that
Club you know he had that uh that
neighborhood sword that's burning down
buildings you feel me he had that sword
you know he had you know he was he had
that backyard sword and so he would come
in and we'd be standing there urinate
and then you see that stream just come
over you you know come over your
shoulder and he had a perfect shot I
mean he was just you know just pistol
PTIN you know he was like Sam Perkins
down there too sleepy Sam just you know
hitting you with just three pointing
over you and he he would drop that over
your shoulder mr. Larry and pissed into
that urinal and he would hit it and it
was just it was pretty cool but that was
like where you got kind of out out
pissed you know you were doing urine but
he came in as a woman I'm gonna up your
urine and I'ma raise you you know I'm a
I'm a see your stream and raise you you
know this beautiful geyser that I'm
working with and he did that mr. Larry
and that's kind of the same thing I
think what this caller is saying that
you know if there's some competition
that there's competition in the works
and that you get that better sperm count
your body just knows intrinsically oh
okay you know there's other raw you know
there's other oysters here trying to
pearl out you know so I'm gonna have to
put a little more sand up under my lip
you know you know they just you you're
nuts know that it's trying to it's not
it's time to first time the full moon
you know it's you can't be sure showing
up with no crescent you know on
Halloween you can't be showing up with
no crescent
you know you know and on Halloween you
gotta show up at that full moon yep then
you gotta fire off decent sperm count
and that's what's happening so thank you
that's interesting I didn't know about
that at all I didn't know about that at
all but that makes sense
you know and that's what I'm saying man
it's all the [ __ ] people are [ __ ]
out there people have this thing inside
of them that wants to dive out of their
body everybody got that Greg Louganis
just hiding at the base of their wieners
trying to dive out of them and that's
dead that's a little bit of the devil
man and that's a little bit of the Lord
and that's where your job is you have to
be your own referee you know what's
gonna pass through these gates right now
am I sitting here in this next spray is
this it for me or who is this for it's
just something that's proper you know or
is this just something that's just a bad
habit you know are you creating
something beautiful or you just nipping
into the neck of another Viet you got to
ask yourself this stuff man because
everybody it's your own journey
everybody it's your own journey so let's
take another call right here man we just
got a few we're not taking a very long
episode today I also want to tell you
you can go to Theo van comm we got some
shirts on there you can grab will have a
new on work shirt that will be going up
this week won't be till later in the
week and we got a guest producer that's
been helping out today Chris so I'm very
grateful to him I want to express
gratitude to him thank you I want to
express gratitude to my boy sure who I
don't know if I read Serbs text the
other day man but it just it was like
the craziest thing that ever happened
man you know he didn't know he was
getting paid this whole time and and
here he'd been helping me out the whole
time if I didn't read those I'll read
them next week but you can check that
out you can grab the two albums that are
out there 30 pound bag of hamster bones
and musket fire you can grab that album
as well it's early satire as well you
can check out the special on Netflix
Netflix com give it a thumbs up
or whatever you have to give it let's
get that thing back into the rotation
you know you gotta support stuff that
you like and you have to do it online
and I know it sounds cheesy but that's
how guys get other opportunities that's
how they do it I want you to support
other podcasts as well I want you to
know that that I said that I appreciate
you guys as support as well a lot of
great calls that came in this week we
had some calls to about the Oregon thing
you know they had the guy that called
him from Oregon and and I might address
that again in the future some of you
guys know what I'm talking about some of
you guys don't but it is having gotten
around and kind of putting it together
right and I'm still kind of thinking
about so my own thoughts on it let's
hear another call right here yo what up
deal this is your boy Luke from
California what's up Luke homeward I
just wanted to get your opinion on some
things that's been going on in my life
I've been the victim of the dark arts
she's last couple of years I'm married
to have a kid you know and I love my
wife I love my kids my kid and but like
I always really had trouble being
monogamous you know in my relationships
and it's not for any you know it's not
because I don't love her my nothing I
don't know I just there's just something
in me bro like that I just can't you
know like I always have to be trying to
have sex with other girls and [ __ ] man
well I appreciate you sending this call
in man let's hear a little bit more and
then I'll see if I can share anything
from my own life experience thank you
for calling no no I stopped beating
myself up about it you know and I tried
looking in like the biology of like
[ __ ] you know you you know like human
biology and [ __ ]
you know other animals see this is
natural or why like I was supposed to be
monogamous as human beings
am I going against my instincts and [ __ ]
you know I don't know but just wanted to
get your opinion on
well I appreciate you calling man I can
certainly relate you know I'm just
hoping these cameras aren't running out
of a video in here but I can certainly
relate I can certainly relate to that
you know having uh you know I don't have
a wife and a child you know so that's
intense because then you're really at
that point you're locking in you know
but I know that struggle of how I've
been in significant relationships before
and not been able to and not being able
to be committed at all you know and um
and I don't even know why you know I
loved you know uh I love the woman that
I was with but if there was just
something wrong with me where nothing
was enough that's what it that's what I
know now is that nothing was enough and
that women or the affection of women was
this weird addiction that I just had to
have you know and it sounds like you
said communicating with other women you
says you know having you know sexual
experiences with other women that sort
of thing but you know you did say
communicate only go back and listen one
more time right here but like I always
really had trouble being monogamous you
know and in my relationships and it's
not for any you know it's not because I
don't love her my nothing I don't know I
just there's just something in me well
like that I just can't you know like I
always have to be trying to have sex
with other girls and [ __ ] yeah yeah you
always have to be and that you know what
it sounds like man it sounds like it cuz
you could take out you could change sex
with women with anything you know always
have to be drinking you know always have
to be thinking negatively about myself
you know I always have to be feeling
like I'm less than you could change it
with anything you could replace it with
anything and at some points I think that
that it's just it's an addictive
behavior you know sometimes we
we can have these isms inside of us
these behaviors inside of us that that
just come out you know and for me mine
would be you know drug use or flirting
with other women I mean I just told you
that I've been through you know similar
experiences with that for sure and it's
just like it's just a you know you say
you don't even want to do it but you
just can't even help it and at that
point that's when for myself I notice
well this is a sickness that I have this
is an affliction this isn't always a
choice that I'm making it's like
something it's like something that I
can't control and when you can't control
it when you're trying to when you don't
want to be doing something and you are
still doing it for me that's when I
notice that it's it's something that's
out of my control it's something that I
need help with and how you can get help
with it you know from experiences of Mon
you can go to sa a meetings that's a sex
addicts anonymous SLA a sex and love
addicts Anonymous you can just go to a a
meetings because in the end it's not
even about you know your alcohol your
drug could be the need to to get
attention intimate and just even verbal
from other women because that's a
sickness man that's a sickness you know
it's good it's fine if you're not of
court look if you're not in a
relationship it's fine you're out there
living you out there sowing seeds you
know you got there John Deering you know
digging holes in that dirt you know I'm
saying and spray you know hoping
something sprouts out that's natural
you know you laying soil in cotton you
laying Milo you got that corn you got
them beats you putting it all in the
ground but if you have a family like
you're saying then your something's
heavier and for me it's just that I'm
it's it goes back to for me that type of
behavior goes back to I believe anyway
some emptiness that I felt a
just that women rejected me or didn't
want me and it could go back to when I
was very young something that happened
that I don't even remember you know it
could go back to just something could
have been happening it you know in
junior high when I was really young
elementary school and junior high you
know is not attractive attractive to
women you know my friends always got the
girls or had interest from the girls I
was always a dude like carrying the love
letter from the girl like to my buddy
you know and you know sometimes that
stuff just does something our in size
where we can't fix it by ourself so
you're not alone man you know you're not
alone and if you can't beat it yourself
then that's when maybe it's not a bad
idea to see if there's other ways to try
and fix it you know because in the end
though you're gonna have to make some
decisions and just say I can't do this
type of behavior you know that doesn't
mean you can't still flirt you know it
does mean you can't still be a man in
ways but when it comes to that line
where you're feeling demoralized after
because you're hooking up are you doing
this for that that's the that's the line
where you have to try and shut it down
you know and look I've done some wild
behaviors man you know I've definitely
done some things that I'm not proud of
I'll actually put a call on next week we
had a caller that called in taking me to
task on a behavior of mine and I'll put
that up next week I'm looking forward to
just sharing that a little bit of that
with you guys and trying to walk through
that a little bit I was I meant to do it
this week but we're getting late in the
episode but thanks for calling man good
luck you know at least you're not being
hard on yourself about it but but not
being hard on yourself that's one thing
but not taking action to repair it you
know that the problem might not go away
and it doesn't sound like it is so you
know I don't want to tell you what to do
but you know if I have a problem and it
doesn't go away then I have to do
something to help help it remedy for me
what I do is I go to a therapist on
Monday and I go to meetings and those
things help
good luck to you man love you let's take
one more call here yeah what's up vo
I was just listening to your most recent
podcast you're talking about that dude
who uh you know is pornography cheating
and he wanted to get you know some other
guy to come drill his wife and all that
no as far as pornography being cheating
at all I don't really think so well as
far as pornography as like a like a dark
art I really think there's something
there is especially with how easy it is
to watch now I'm really talking about
like with with young young kids like
with young men oh hundred percent cat
daddy a hundred percent that pornography
is easy think about it you could be
looking for a box of cereal and next
thing you know you watching gangbangs
Howie Howie
never has there been something as
insanely accessible as pornography it's
crazy it's crazy how accessible it is I
don't if I were I no wonder there aren't
any more twelve-year-old kids playing in
the front yard anymore they are jerking
off everywhere there's no way if I were
12 dude I remember being 12 years old or
11 going to the library you know and had
this this author or something peter paul
rubens I think was his name he was a
paint warlord artist he was an artist
and he had these are these to draw these
rubenesque women laying in the bushes
this is unlike the eighteen sixteen
seventeen hundreds or something and dude
I would crack those books open and I
would catch that bone
you know I catch that bone down between
me and I would put that bone between the
books on the pictures of these ladies
you know these voluptuous ladies and I
would just kind of close the book
against my boner until I you know until
my boner just gave up the ghost you know
just threw that liquid Casper up into
the air and that's when I was out you
know and I must have
I mean I was tormenting I was tormenting
the 16 and 1700 art encyclopedias in the
library there but I was just young and
that's the first look I got at that
crotch you know and then we had later
you had to pay this boy in junior high
school to dress he is the only one that
could draw you some cooter he had the
best drawings so if you want to have
some cooter for the weekend you'd have
him draw you a picture of it you know
dropping two dollars you know 275 and
he'd sketch up a heart of some nice
cooter but now these kids dealing with
pornography I can't even imagine I can't
dude there's no way I would just be
driving to school not watching sex on my
phone if I were 13 14 years old
there's no way so I don't see how these
kids are navigating it and maybe they're
doing it fine maybe it's just like in
Europe where it's like you know just
because you can drink doesn't mean you
do you know doesn't mean there's a
million car accidents I was in Canada
this weekend they can drink at 18 you
know I didn't notice a ton of kids just
you know you know crashing cars in a
bill you know constantly ruining their
lives they might have a problem but I
didn't hear anything about it maybe it's
one of those things where you know kids
are taking care of it better where there
are a little bit more conscientious I
don't know you know I've got to look
into that and see what some of the
effects are of this pornography on young
people but where do I even find accurate
information about it I mean I how dare I
read a news article that [ __ ] is come on
it's crazy I just have no idea what's
going on anymore but it's also kind of
freeing know in the news is just
juggling [ __ ] it's kind of freeing
isn't it oh we don't know what's
happening
nobody's gonna tell the truth anymore
thank God good because I think you got
to get to the bottom of something before
you can uh before you can see what's
there you know you got to get to the
bottom of something before you can see
what's there because you can't see what
you can't see but I appreciate you guys
calling man there's been you know III
didn't know what tonight's episode was
sometimes I don't even know what what
talk about her what to get into but I
feel blessed that I have the ability to
come here and share some time with you
guys let's take this woman last call hey
brother how you doing man it's Christian
here calling in from Dublin I just
wanted to call and say you know again
thank you for sharing your thoughts and
issues with relationships and you know I
kind of relate to it mum you know it's
kind of [ __ ] up but I find what I do a
lot of the time is I end up going for
these girls that I know I'm not gonna
have a meaningful connection with coz
it's safer I don't have to deal with
actually connecting with them ultimately
you know dealing with loss or dealing
with rejection or yeah a hundred percent
I appreciate you calling man and I've
actually put the call and Kyle I want to
hear that accent man something just
takes you back where you want to just
damn turn into Sean William Scott er who
is it no not Sean William Scott that's
the guy from doodle-dudes where's my
cars this is uh William Wallace you know
oh you not with your country William
always and he uh but yeah you're right
man
you know yeah you don't want to jump you
don't want to jump in you don't want to
there's I think there's a lot going on
one is you know there's so much access
these days just to you know to other
women too is yeah you don't want to we
don't want to grow up getting married
committing ourselves it's growing up
it's given up you know three is you know
we're afraid you know maybe we have
weird relationships with our mother so I
don't know how to how to treat women
you know and four is I think some of us
you know we just want to live we have
this thing like we want to live forever
and if if we do things that make us grow
up or that seemed like that grown-ups do
or that you know getting married
starting I have a family those types of
things being committed promising your
affections loving someone if we do those
types of things and really do them then
it feels like we're giving up a piece of
our immortality
if that makes any sense and then I'm not
trying to sign egomaniacal with that but
I'm just trying to sound like some stuff
I'm thinking about those are things I'm
thinking about man lay off the ranch
dressing huh how about that if somebody
gets you a keg of ranch dressing
question who they are you know or [ __ ]
it paint your house with the [ __ ] you
know damn I love being over here what
color is that
huh remoulade what color is that Italian
I love it I love you guys man be good
take care of yourselves I will I will
see you guys next week we may do a
Thursday episode we may not I'm gonna
throw some stuff up on patreon for the
patreon errs thank you guys and uh and
Happy Holidays start the season now
start the season now get in your car
turn on the [ __ ] Christmas carols no
one's gonna be mad with the Christmas
carols going nobody promised you you
can't be furious with rockin around
[Music]
figure it out I'm gonna try to thanks
for help me get through it you guys be
good happy whatever it is to you today
birthday Monday Wednesday Thursday
nothing funeral I'm gonna go watch
funerals on the internet love you be
good to yourselves because you probably
deserve it
[Music]
celebrate